There is a huge ocean of light that is
flowing from within everyone.
Every year we travel 200 kilometers
in the mountains and deserts.
It is our spiritual journey. It
is very hot during this 14 day journey.
Here in the mountains, we face a lot of difficulties.
When we walk on the path of returning to the mountain,
our penance is as if there will be more in the future [
Music]
We are all brothers in this journey [
Music] [
Music]
Whatever is enough in the journey
[Music]
Life  Every
[music]
Kim's people are
in it
[music]
giving way to a lot of people [music] I
try to [
music] [
music]
[praise] the one
who has the
most power in the world
[Music]
As long as I have this life in my legs
and if there is passion, every destination will be easy, regardless of caste
[Music]